ضربه البت في قلبها في قلبها مباشره
وقعت لي متوفيه توفى الطوال في الحال
ليست مجرد
احد بل مصيبه في
عبر الوالد عن وجعه كثيرا توفيت ابنته
الطبيبه الاء فلم يكفها الرثاء لاحقها
والدها بوفاته بعد ايام
انفطر قلبه عليها الاء لقد حتفها في اليوم
الخامس من الاشتباكات رصاصه طائشه استقرت
في قلبها امام والدها بعد عودتها من عملها
يعني الشارع فاضي الناس كلها اختفت في
بيوته فدخلت خوف على اساس
العربيه ما شاء
بالاحياء جابوا
وصلت
واخذت خمس دقائق
مواقع التواصل استفقت على حادثه وفاه
الكابتن الرياضي فوزي المرضي بعد ايام من
وفاه ابنته الشابه
ذهول وتفاعل غير مسبوق والحكم واحد قلبه
لم يحتمل
[موسيقى]
مدينه شهدت على حكايات اخرى ايضا وفيات
بالمئات وبين تلك الارقام قصص انسانيه لا
حصر لها ولا حدود لالمها ربما غذاء السالم
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات